So yesterday I explained to you that while
Donald Trump was complaining that the Federal
Reserve didn't give him the big
federal funds rate cut that he wanted.
He was deliberately ignoring that from August
1st on his additional tariffs on China have
really been hurting the stock market.
And yesterday when we were producing the show,
I said, as of right now, the stock market,
the Dow is down nearly 600 points and it ended
down more than 700 points.
The worst day in 2019 so far.
And the reason is Donald Trump's trade war,
which includes now China devaluing its currency,
which I'll talk about momentarily, and it
is getting worse and worse.
This is going to be terrible for Americans
of all kinds.
There are all sorts of moralistic arguments
we can make about China and their behavior,
but in the end, this is bad for Americans.
Now the Dow is down nearly 6% and just this
month, it's August 6th [inaudible] through
August 5th which we had two weekend trading
days or rather two weekend days that we're
not trading days down nearly 6% the Dow back
down roughly to where it was in January of
2018 which is 19 months ago, s and p 500 down
about 3% yesterday, Nasdaq down even more,
3.5% so this is bad and it's bad even for
people who don't necessarily own lots of shares
of stock as I've described before.
And you know what?
China is going to keep messing with Donald
Trump now that Donald Trump has declared a
trade war war on China, a type of war.
Nevertheless, China has now allowed the yacht
yuan their currency to weaken beyond seven
yon per dollar for the first time in 10 years.
And Donald Trump is attacking them on Twitter
saying quote, China drop the price of their
currency to an almost a historic low.
It's called currency manipulation.
Are you listening?
The Federal Reserve, this is a major violation
which will greatly weaken China over time.
Really get the feeling that Trump has China
on the ropes.
Right?
Like any second, China's going to relent and
come to the table and give Donald Trump everything
he wants.
Yeah, obviously not.
And it's important to understand this currency
manipulation allegation, which is not untrue.
By the way.
China does manipulate the value of their currency
for trade benefit purposes by reducing the
value of their currency.
It makes it cheaper for other countries to
buy stuff from China to import to their countries.
If you get more yuan per dollar, you can now
get more Chinese stuff per dollar effectively
making it cheaper.
That's true.
And it's not going to change the way that
Donald Trump has been handling Chinese trade
policy.
It's having the predicted effect, which is
that it's crashing out our stock markets.
And in more bad news for the United States,
China has asked state owned companies to just
stop buying agricultural imports from the
United States altogether.
So if you thought that American farmers had
been getting crushed for the last nine months
and they have been, as I've told you about,
that has been nothing compared to what you
are about to see upcoming.
This isn't sustainable, but more importantly,
Trump doesn't even understand how this stuff
works.
Trump's policy to the extent you can call
it policy, is driven by misunderstandings
about the most fundamental elements of trade
and economics and currency combined with this
attitude that he has of everything being a
win, lose negotiation and who's the strongest
and who's going to come out on top.
Trump's so-called business experience, which
was the reason that many people voted for
the guy to begin with.
His business experience we were told would
translate really well to being president and
we knew that that was a joke.
Anyone who had any common sense knew that
was a joke.
Trump's business experience, his daddy gave
you money to get started.
Everyone around you was constantly Brown nosing
and you just ignored all the, all the rules
all the time while bossing people around things
are different now.
Yes, Trump, what hasn't changed is Trump has
still surrounded himself with the Brown nosing
sycophants that's the same as when Trump was
in business.
But Trump has tried taking the same sort of
attitude with China and China is not, you
know, some concrete or steel company that
Trump has over a barrel.
This is not looking good period.
No matter your political affiliation.
And that's what I hope people understand.
It doesn't matter whether you're for or against
abortion, this is bad, bad, bad.
There's no sign of it getting better, particularly
when the president sees it all as sport wins
and losses without even understanding what
the definition of winning actually is, it's
going to get even worse.
Unfortunately.